[Music]  in every movie i watch from the 50s  there's only one thought that swirls  around my head now  and that's hit everyone there on the  screen  everyone there on the screen oh they're  all dead now  they're all dead now  it ain't easy living  i can't help but keep falling  [Music]  i'm daydreaming in black and white until  it passes  till it passes  [Music]  i don't want to feel the pressure  of god  or  [Music]  whatever these  days hard to relax you gotta hold a gun  to my back to make me smile  make me smile  and the only way i see the cope  is  [Music]  from  [Music]  or whatever  holy rollers  keep rolling  while the searchers  keep scrolling  [Music]  oh  [Music]  or whatever  [Music]  i don't wanna feel the pressure  [Music]  [Applause]